you've finally done it after years of
adding movies and shows to your queues
you've officially run out of things to
watch on netflix you've also exhausted
your entire backlog of books and you've
even run out of cereal boxes to read so
you're left roaming the streets in
search of entertainment that's when you
see a worn looking flyer stapled to a
nearby telephone pole it's an ad for a
local community theater production of a
play you've never heard of a play called
the hanged kings tragedy normally you
wouldn't think of yourself as much of a
theater person but something about the
art on the poster grabs you there's a
strange figure on the poster its face
shrouded its body wrapped in a web of
chains your curiosity gets the better of
you and you check the performance date
to your pleasant surprise opening night
is a week from now and you don't have
anything planned you've made up your
mind you're going to attend a live
performance of the hanged kings tragedy
it's going to be the first live play
you've ever seen and little do you know
it may also be
the last because the hang king's tragedy
isn't just any old play it's a powerful
and deadly memetic hazard that may be
one of the gateways to an even more
dangerous being it's known to the scp
foundation as
scp-701 so take your seats be sure to
read your programs thoroughly and
prepare for the dark and terrifying tale
of the hanged king's tragedy and the
wave of death and destruction it causes
in its theatrical wake but how could you
know any of this while you head home to
make dinner looking forward to seeing
the new plane next week the local
thespians are hard at work performing
dress rehearsals the director one marcus
fitch happened upon a copy of the play
while looking for carolinian theater
that's a little more family friendly
than some of the shakespearean classics
when he'd first discovered the hanged
king's tragedy on a theatrical forum it
was described as being similar to
shakespeare's hamlet and titus
andronicus but the violence was largely
offstage and implied with a lot of the
play's nastier elements glossed over
perfect for audience of all ages given
the fact that performances of the hang
king's tragedy tend to be mass casualty
events for reasons you'll soon see the
foundation does everything they can to
control the spread of the play's script
all copies are kept in a triple locked
vault in a secure foundation archive
which currently includes two copies of
the original publication that are dated
to the year 1640 27 copies of the 1965
trade paperback edition 10 copies of a
1971 hardcover printing 21 floppy
diskettes containing the play script and
one svhs video cassette tape containing
a live taping of one particularly
infamous incident however this seemingly
does little to prevent new performances
of the hanged king's tragedy from
occurring the text of the play
continually pops up online often under
different or misspelled titles
preventing foundation web crawlers from
keeping track of them all nevertheless
the foundation does everything in its
power to detect and stop performances
before they can go ahead the danger of
putting on or even viewing a performance
of the hang king's tragedy cannot be
overstated it's believed that in the
almost 300 years since its original
publication it's claimed 10 000 lives
through performances at the very least
and if you're in attendance dying
quickly is one of the better outcomes
the origins of this mometic virus are
just as mysterious as the power that
seems to drive its effects the plane
never had a declared author and the
publisher one william cook disappeared
from all historical records after the
play's publications performances have
been varied over the 300 years the play
has been active it's been spotted
everywhere from british university drama
troops to american high school plays in
what could have been an even more
disastrous tragedy a television
adaptation of the play was almost
broadcast by the bbc before the
foundation stepped in and put a stop to
it while its containment classification
is currently euclid scientists who have
studied the play have campaigned
strongly to upgrade the hang king's
tragedy to keter class on account of its
unpredictability and tendency to
manifest across the globe with
incidences appearing decades apart while
members of the o5 council are skeptical
some researchers even believe that given
a wide enough exposure the hang kings
tragedy could cause a dreaded xk class
end of the world scenario it is that
dangerous at this point you're probably
wondering what exactly is the hang
king's tragedy what's the play even
about as the name suggests the play is a
tragedy and takes place over five acts
during the carolinian era portraying the
drama of the royal court much like a
number of plays from that time did it
takes place in the city of serco the
capital of the mysterious fictional
kingdom of trinculo the focal point of
the play is the conflict between gonzalo
the illegitimate king of trincolo and
antonio the true heir to the throne
before the start of the play the
previous king of trinculo king sephorza
had been betrayed and murdered by
gonzalo gonzalo led sephorza into the
woods where he and his men subdued the
king and hanged him from a nearby tree
like a common criminal hence the hanged
king's tragedy however gonzalo is trying
to keep his part in the king's murder a
secret to keep the throne for himself
but his guild-stricken wife isabella
threatens to spill the secret of
sephora's murder while antonio tries to
uncover the truth of what happened in
the woods gonzalo in true shakespearean
villain style plots further murders of
his co-conspirators and loose ends to
keep his dark secrets safe this is where
the play gets a little gruesome one
enemy gonzalo had killed and cooked into
a stew he then intends to use this stew
to murder his entire court with the help
of an effective and undetectable poison
he was given by the mysterious
ambassador of alagadda though you'll be
pleased to know that this tragedy has
somewhat of a happy ending in the end
gonzalo is exposed and antonio claims
his rightful place as king of trinculo
unlike his predecessor antonio decides
to show mercy and gonzalo is exiled to a
monastery for life rather than being
executed for his murderous ways the
heroes are rewarded the villains are
punished and all the deserving parties
live happily ever after at face value
nothing seems off about the play if
you're familiar with other works of the
era you might even find yourself getting
bored while reading it how can something
this
normal be the curse play that claims so
many thousands of lives but this play's
unassuming nature only serves to make it
more dangerous it doesn't appear that
the memetic hazard is caused by simply
reading the play like all good theater
it only truly comes to life on stage and
your local production of the hang king's
tragedy is no exception as your
community's amateur actors study and
rehearse the play making sure to commit
every scene every line every single word
to memory they don't notice the little
things that to an outsider might seem a
little off
occasionally during group dress
rehearsals actors will veer from the
script and we're not talking about flood
lines or simple improvisation no actors
will at times seem like they're reading
from a completely different script and
their fellow performers will respond in
kind the play lulls you into a false
sense of security stagehands crew
members even the director all believe
they're performing the play exactly as
it was originally written okay so that's
not so bad a play that changes itself
but things are going to get worse from
this point
much much worse but hey why let a deadly
anomaly ruin your evening plans you've
been looking forward to seeing this play
all week and you couldn't seem to get
that figure from the poster out of your
mind
you have no idea that this entity is
wanted by the scp foundation and that
its designation is scp-701-1
all you want is an unforgettable theater
experience and you will certainly
get one it's a packed house not an empty
seat in sight the house lights dim and
the curtain opens act one is quite
normal with all the backstabbing and
royal court intrigue you'd expect you
actually feel yourself getting a little
bored a big yawn escapes your mouth
you're thinking that maybe this was a
big mistake and you might sneak out
between acts when just then you see it
in the final scene of act one you see
the shrouded figure lingering in the
background against the curtains he seems
so still he's almost like a shadow but
as each act seems to run into the next
he becomes more prominent the rest of
the cast never acknowledges him as they
deliver dramatic monologues but he's
always
there
finally the play reached act five the
grand banquet scene where it all comes
to head gonzalo is preparing to poison
his dinner guests with his cannibal stew
while antonio and his allies plot to
reveal his terrible crimes and dethrone
him you find yourself so gripped by the
drama of it all you almost didn't notice
that the shrouded figure of
scp-701-1 was standing right among the
actors now while unbeknownst to you the
actors have been deviating from the
scripted story this whole time things
are about to really take a turn for the
horrific
scp-701-1 who is now known to the other
performers as the hanged king produces a
blade from thin air and passes it to the
actor playing gonzalo's wife the actors
on stage suddenly become entranced they
attack and restrain gonzalo and a noose
drops down from somewhere above the
stage the actors proceed to
ritualistically hang gonzalo before the
actor playing his wife stabs him to
death all while chanting blood for the
hanged king you should be horrified but
you're not you don't even feel like
yourself anymore and you're loving
everything that's happening on stage a
series of other nooses fall from above
each actor grabs their own noose and the
cass repeats blood for the hanged king
before sacrificing their lives to the
shroud wearing monster if the carnage
stopped there it would be bad enough but
this play doesn't just drive its players
to acts of violent insanity it pulls in
the audience too before you know it
you're pulled into a vicious brawl with
your fellow theater goers there's biting
clawing punching people hitting each
other with chairs like it's a wrestling
cage match it's such a frenzy of random
senseless violence that the building
can't contain it anymore you and anyone
else who isn't dead already spilled out
onto the streets and start attacking
everyone you can get your hands on it's
transformed from a pleasant night out at
the theater into a full-blown riot even
the police sent in to control the
situation are overwhelmed it isn't until
the scp foundation sends a number of
mobile task forces trained in advanced
crowd control that the situation finally
begins to de-escalate but you don't care
even when large men in foundation
tactical gear are holding your arms you
still try to bite and kick the effects
of the play normally wear off after
around 24 hours but until then the
infected including you are just rage
fueled monsters in the end it takes 4
adult men to properly restrain you
you'll feel the bruises from their
nightsticks tomorrow but now all you
feel is hate and violence and a
single-minded devotion to something out
there that you couldn't possibly
comprehend and the whole time you're
screaming one thing over and over
again
blood for the hanged king
now go watch
scp-610 zombie plague the flesh that
hates and scp-3999
i am at the center of everything that
happens to me for more horrific stories
from the files of the foundation